do you want to know how to learn a
language as fast as possible are you
interested in Saving so much time that
you end up reaching fluency in months
rather than years after 30 years of
learning languages and 10 coaching
others to do the same I believe I
finally figured out and today I'm going
to share it all with you I'm going to
tell you how I would go about learning
as much language as possible within 90
days if that sounds interesting to you
keep watching and don't forget to stay
until the end if you do you'll get to
hear the one piece of advice that will
ensure you that you too can learn a
language really really fast hi I'm Lucas
I'm a Language Coach who speaks 14
languages and on this channel I help
people learn foreign languages more
efficiently faster and in a fun way so
how do you learn a language super fast
let's find out not too long ago I spent
a month visiting Budapest the capital
city of Hungary while I was there I
became friends with Jonathan a Belgian
guy who happened to speak Hungarian I
know a little Hungarian myself but as I
went around the city with him I remember
being in awe of the comfort and fluency
with which he spoke the language curious
I asked him how long he had been
learning Hungarian for given his
apparent skill I expected this answer to
be anywhere in the range of 10 to 15
years but no he hadn't been learning for
15 years 10 years or anything in between
in reality he had begun learning
Hungarian only two years prior to my
visit to years I've been learning
Hungarian for seven years at that point
and I was barely conversational so what
gives what did this guy know about
language learning that I somehow did not
what essential piece of the puzzle was I
missing that prevented me from learning
Hungarian at that Breakneck speed now
even more Curious I asked him to tell me
as much as he could about his history
with Hungarian I hope that the details
of his story would reveal something that
I could use to improve my own language
during speed too the whole story is too
long to recount here but here are the
most pertinent details he began learning
Hungarian in a school that followed an
immersion learning model even from day
one the students were not allowed to
speak any other language but Hungarian
shorty after that he moved in with his
then Turkish girlfriend and they decided
to use only Hungarian with each other
after a few short months of a lifestyle
in which both his home and school lives
were all in Hungarian my friend was able
to speak reasonably well and he had only
gotten better since that time
this was fascinating to me Hungarian is
not an easy language to learn for nearly
anyone it's not really related to any
other languages in Europe with the
exception maybe a Finnish and Estonian
so most people learning the language
would struggle to speak a well even
after a few years myself included but as
I've just described my Belgian friends
circumstances were very special he was
able to immerse himself in the language
practically from his very first day of
learning and that gave him some immense
advantages over most Learners of
Hungarian but what about those other
Learners what about people like you and
me who want to learn languages quickly
but don't have the benefits of an
immersion school and a Hungarian
speaking significant other what can we
do to learn a language and do it really
fast like my friend did I think I have
the answer but before I share it with
you let's begin by defining exactly what
it means to learn a language clarifying
this definition will give us a much
better understanding of our goal so that
we know exactly what kind of Target
we're aiming to hit by the end of our
90-day period lots of people disagree on
what it actually means to have have
learned a language or become fluent for
some people it means merely being able
to communicate well for others it means
having a solid Mastery of the language
as an educated native speaker might
personally I only consider a language
learned when I've reached a very
specific skill level that level in fact
is one of the six levels described by
the common European framework of
reference for languages or cefr if
you're not familiar the cefr is what we
use in Europe to measure language
proficiency the cefr has six levels A1
A2 B1 B2 C1 and C2 in my opinion fluency
begins at the second half of that range
precisely at the B2 level according to
the Council of Europe the organization
in charge of the cefr someone at a B2
level is able to understand most TV news
and current affairs programs as well as
the majority of films in standard
dialect interact with the degree of
fluency and spontaneity that makes
regular interaction with native speakers
quite possible present and clear detail
descriptions on a wide range of subjects
related to one's field of Interest
in my experience a B2 level in a
language is not something that it's
generally possible for any learner to
achieve in three months no matter the
language there's quite simply too much
to learn and too little time to do it if
you're interested in learning more about
why I feel this way please check out my
video about the myth of reaching fluency
in for months a link to which should be
popping up now in the corner of your
screen on the other hand I believe three
months is entirely enough time to reach
a level of B1 which is the level just
below B2 on the cefr scale let's take a
look now at what that entails according
to the cefr Learners at a B1 level can
understand the main points of clear
standard input on familiar matters
regularly encountered in work school
Leisure Etc deal with most situations
likely to arise while traveling in an
area where the language is spoken can
produce simple connected text on topics
which are familiar or of personal
interest describe experiences and events
dreams hopes and and Ambitions and
briefly give reasons and explanations
for opinions and plans to me those
capabilities mesh well with what I think
of when I consider a language learned
and together they are things that a
dedicated language learner can
accomplish within 90 days okay now that
we've decided to only call a language
learned when our skills reach the
criteria for a B1 level let's define
another term fast
when we say we want to learn a language
fast how fast do we actually mean this
is pretty subjective since three days
three weeks or even three months can all
be considered pretty quick from a
learning perspective however for the
purposes of this video we'll stick with
three months or 90 days this might not
be fast by some people's standards but
it's definitely a short period of time
compared to the three or four years it
likely took us all to become fluent in
our mother tongues or right with our key
definitions out of the way you're now
ready to learn exactly how I would go
about learning a language fast or in
other words how I would reach a B1 level
in three months let's Dive Right In
before I share this plan let me explain
a few things first I'll share this plan
as a series of steps that you can follow
in order to learn a language fast second
our end goal of B1 in three months is
only realistic if your target language
is similar to your native language if
you're a native English speaker learning
say Japanese the time period to reach
fluency needs to be adjusted to six or
nine months instead of three and last in
terms of General structure I'll be
explaining the steps month by month and
describing what you should do in each
month in terms of three things what you
should do how you should do it and when
you should do it
so let's begin with month one month one
what
to begin your quest for fluency you need
a good beginner language course to
follow the best in my opinion are the
with E series of course books provided
by Asimo you can find them online by
searching for Spanish with ease French
with ease Hungarian with these and so on
and so forth asimos courses are
particularly handy because of their
excellent content and structure
typically they consist of small portable
course books that contain around 100
authentic and interesting target
language dialogues each dialogue comes
with audio a translation into English or
some other language you know well and
short but helpful grammar notes
typically assimil is the only resource I
recommend for the beginner stages of
learning but since we want to go fast
I'll recommend another resource to use
at the same time Innovative languages
pod 101 or class one-on-one language
courses these courses all of which have
names like Greek pod 101 or Korean class
101 are essentially massive collections
of audio and video lessons each
dedicated to a specific language they
often contain tons of and take useful
language content that is delivered
alongside English translations grammar
notes and all sorts of other useful
information access to these courses is
subscription based but there are a bunch
of different pricing options to choose
from so you can usually obtain a lot of
high quality language content at very
little expense and there's even a free
trial best of all pod 101 courses are
not just limited to beginner content
I've learned several languages using
these courses and they've served me well
from the beginner level all the way to
Advanced proficiency so that's how I
would start after choosing my target
language say Dutch I would pick up Asimo
Dutch with ease and then the appropriate
Innovative language course Dutch pod 101
how now that we have our resources we
need to know how to use them if we
wanted to go at a normal Pace I would
say pick either Asimo or pod 101 and do
one lesson a day but our pace of course
is anything but normal we want to go
fast so we need to do more each day a
lot more specifically I recommend
covering 3 three lessons of acetamol and
three lessons of pod 101 every single
day but how exactly should we go about
doing these lessons well I recommend the
following first read the content and
listen to the accompanying audio at the
same time next read the text in your
target language and try to focus on the
meaning
after that just listen to the audio by
itself and focus on the sounds of the
language
once you're comfortable with the sounds
try to read the text out loud to
yourself in an effort to build your
pronunciation skills listen to the audio
again and repeat what you hear as soon
as you hear it
this is a technique called shadowing it
will help you really improve your
articulation when you're done with all
that review the grammar notes that come
with a lesson to help clarify any doubts
you might have that sounds like a lot
and it is but we're not quite done yet
in addition to covering six new lessons
each day three Aston Mill and three pod
101 you should also review the six
lessons you learned the previous day
either by re-reading or re-listening to
their content
that's a lot to manage I know but this
kind of intensity is essential if you
want to attempt a B1 in three months by
the way if you're curious how to do all
this at a more reasonable speed check
the link in the description box to learn
about my bi-directional translation
method course which teaches a lighter
version of this approach for people who
want to Simply reach the intermediate
level an A2 or B1 in three months let's
talk about the when we've got our
resources and we know what activities we
need to do but for our first month when
should we actually do these things first
off you'll have to do this every single
day if you skip any days it becomes much
less like you you will learn your target
language within the three month period
next you must keep in mind that I'm
recommending that you cover 12 language
lessons each day six new lessons and six
old lessons as review for most people
that will take up to three hours each
day try not to exceed three hours though
since that might lead to burnout which
is the opposite of what we want do your
best to schedule these three hours of
learning when you have the most energy
that will give your brain the best
chance of absorbing the new material
take breaks here and there as you need
but always try to make sure you're
learning when you're most focused and
engaged in the tasks at hand on to month
two month two what at the end of the
first month you likely will have
completed all of your assimil course
book and most if not all of the beginner
content from pod 101. from here you can
continue on with pod 101 if you'd like
however I recommend trying a couple of
new resources as well link you and lingo
pie these resources are useful at this
stage because they're usable with a wide
variety of authentic language materials
specifically linkq is great for learning
from podcasts and lingo pie is great for
learning from videos more specifically
linkq is a language learning platform
that helps users learn and practice new
Languages by providing access to a wide
range of lessons and activities as well
as tools for tracking progress and
monitoring comprehension
linkq offers a variety of features
including a dictionary and flashcards
and allows users to import content from
various sources such as websites books
and podcasts in order to create
personalized language lessons the
platform also provides a community of
language Learners where users can
interact and support each other in their
language learning journey I used it
extensively for a number of languages
and in particular I had a real blast
using it to improve Mandarin Chinese
lingo pie is a platform that provides a
vast library of high quality content in
the form of video it has a stunning
design and it is fun to use it has
excellent and VAST TV content in many
popular languages such as Spanish French
Italian German Russian and Portuguese
and it is great for Learners in that it
has a number of features such as double
subtitles that make the whole learning
experience Pleasant and rewarding in
short both of these resources are
repositories of language content that is
made comprehensible for Learners thanks
to a variety of tools that each service
offers if you'd like to check them out
for yourself look for my affiliate link
links down in the description box
both of these platforms have tons of
great content to choose from and Link
you even has the option for you to
upload your own authentic text so you
can technically make a podcast out of
any text you want
when using linkq and lingo Pi you should
follow two key guidelines first only
learn with content you find interesting
if you don't find something interesting
you'll be much less likely to actually
learn from it so when choosing content
remember to always follow the fun second
try to learn with content that you
mostly understand but do not completely
understand this kind of content is what
I like to call both comprehensible and
Rich
so try to learn rich and comprehensible
content every day you've already been
doing this with assimil and pod 101 but
using linkq and lingo Pi will open you
up to a lot more challenging content
that covers a wider range of content
that your beginner materials could not
in the second half of month two you
might even want to hire a tutor which
you can do relatively cheaply using
services like italki and pre-ply the
goal here is to speak but you want to
follow the same theme of learning and
discussing content and topics that
heavily interest you do not focus so
much on speaking perfectly just speak
and listen as much as you can and your
accuracy will steadily and gradually
improve now let's talk about the win as
with month one I recommend that you
continue learning for at least three
hours a day during month two if you can
however try to push for four hours a day
you should be more accustomed to intense
learning at this point so learning for
this long should not burn you out like
it would in the previous month adding
another learning hour to your day will
give you more time to cover a greater
range of language learning content as
provide a link you with lingo Pi but it
also gives you time to fit in the
tutoring that I mentioned a few moments
ago speaking of tutoring I recommend
scheduling at least two lessons every
week at a rate of one every three days
or so this will help keep costs low and
give you an opportunity to review
between each lesson month three what
for this month the answer to what you
should be learning is simply more of the
same you should be very comfortable with
intermediate level podcasts and videos
in your target language now so for this
month you should try to broaden your
content base and learn from content on
an increasingly wide range of topics
fortunately YouTube has a near endless
amount of videos in a huge variety of
languages so if you change your YouTube
location to a country where your target
language is spoken you can get a lot of
material as you go through more content
try to strike a balance between quantity
watching as many videos as possible and
quality watching videos which most
closely suit your interests you can also
increase your ability to learn from
YouTube videos by using handy subtitling
and translation tools like those
provided by language reactor more about
them in the description box month three
you can also continue working with your
tutor if you feel like it you can even
look into hiring a psycho tutor just so
that you can gain experience talking to
different people let's talk about the
how the how for month three is roughly
the same as a month two just read and
listen to as much content as you can in
the same way as you've already been
doing similarly you can keep having
conversations with your tutor on a wide
range of topics that interest you and
now let's talk about the when so for the
when of month three you will want to
ramp things up even further assuming you
took my advice from month two and are
learning for four hours a day for this
month you should push for a full five
hours of learning every single day with
the extra hour of learning you'll gain a
lot of benefit for more frequent
speaking practice so this is the right
time to move up to three to four
conversations per week rather than the
original one or two per week this will
help you inch even closer to
conversational fluency by the end of the
month at the end of month three you will
probably want a way to determine if
you've achieved your goal of fluency
your target language a good way to do
this is to see if you can manage a full
30 minute conversation with a native
speaker where you're speaking
comfortably and confidently and with
little difficulty
if you can manage that I'd say you've
definitely reached your goal
this of course is not an objective
measure of your skill compared to the B1
level of the cefr that's only truly
attainable for studying for an official
cefr test which might take you longer
than three months to do but if you're
looking for that objective measure then
that's something you should look towards
doing next speaking of next that reminds
me whether or not you're able to have a
30 minute conversation in your target
language or even pass a B1 exam you
should plan on continuing to learn your
target language there's no real Finish
Line in language learning so you should
always be open to learning more and
improving your skills in new ways okay
that was a long one but we're just about
done before we go though let's do a
quick recap of everything we've talked
about here first it is possible to learn
a language super fast but it's
impossible to know what that really
means until you define your terms in my
book a language can be considered a
learned when you reach a B1 level and
doing that fast would mean getting it
done in about three months and then if I
wanted to reach a B1 level in three
months I would follow this plan in month
one I would grab two beginner resources
asimil and pod 101 and cover 12 lessons
a day six new and six old for three
hours a day at most in month two I would
use Link queue and lingo pi to expand my
learning content to authentic podcasts
and videos respectively I would also
begin meeting with a tutor for
conversational practice and fit all of
these activities into at least four
hours a day in month three I would do
all of the same things I planned for
month two but it would broaden the range
of content I learned from and up the
intensity of my learning plan this means
learning for at least five hours a day
and meeting with a tutor three or four
times a week
at the end of all that I would determine
if I reached my goal by challenging
myself to have a comfortable
conversation with a native speaker for
at least 30 minutes additionally if I
had the time and inclination I might
even sign up to take a B1 proficiency
exam oh and by the way if you want a
more in-depth look at the steps I take
to learn any language from the very
beginning check out my course become a
master language learner level one the
bi-directional translation method in the
course I go into exhaustive detail on my
most powerful language learning
technique and show you exactly how you
can put into practice yourself in your
own life
that's all for me for now thanks for
watching and as always happy language
learning